first I'm going to say uh I congrats on
the movie I had I watched without
knowing where exactly what was going on
like I hadn't seen a trailer or anything
and uh it kept me guessing for I'm just
gonna say congrats
thank you uh justice I want to start
with you
um so the last time I saw you was in
Brazil and I'm just curious uh how much
you enjoyed standing in front of
thousands of people trying to promote
something Sebastian is probably used to
it
um it was my second time doing it
um I have a mint in my mouth and it's
not
I'm doing it so it wasn't as like wow as
the first time but it was still like
pretty wow uh I I have this fascination
with being on stage and being watched
but not doing anything like specifically
when like other people would answer
questions I would just look at the crowd
and I was like I'm home
I'm being watched I don't know what it
is about my personal I'm a narcissist or
something I don't know I just really
like sitting there and being observed I
don't know I don't know what that is I'm
addicted to that feeling I wish that's
not the answer I was expecting
um
you've obviously done stuff where you're
standing in front of thousands of people
talking about promoting something I'm
curious if you enjoy that or is it
something that you're in your head a
little bit
I always uh I always just wonder how I'm
gonna get through that uh for about like
the first hour up to and then once I
finally get outside like the energy is
usually so impactful that I actually
kind of
you know get excited in a way in it and
it and then it just feels like I'm more
present than than I ever would think I
am but it's always sort of like this you
know I mean we're not
some of us we're not rock stars you know
like I was gonna say I don't know maybe
just as you are I have no idea but in my
heart you know it's just you're yeah
like it's like this is what maybe being
at a concert you know that you on that
stage it's just it's a wild feeling
uh Sebastian you danced in fresh uh and
you dance in this movie and I'm just
curious if that means it's in your
contract going forward stay alive Steve
that's that's it you know still the best
I can if someone has actually never seen
anything you've done before what is the
first thing you'd like them watching and
why someone has never seen anything that
we've done before what's the first thing
we would like them to watch
like from our career it's funny you
should say that because there's a way to
prepare for this I actually sent uh
Brianna a gift set of the Gossip Girl uh
series that I was involved in and I just
I just said to her I don't know you
might want to watch this before we enter
into this scene yeah it's a good prep
good prep it helped I like to call
methods too right I I've heard that
about you for me
uh what would I want people to watch of
mine if they never
I have a lot of stuff that I'm really
proud of and I have a lot of stuff that
I'm not as proud of and uh
uh I would say probably the get down
yeah probably get down that's good
baslerman oh man baby yeah that was a
good show that was a fun experience yeah
got about two choices so I'll go with
this one tomorrow
I also enjoyed your work in tender bar
you could say that thanks uh Thunderbolt
was amazing thanks this is great yeah
and that was such an entirely different
character I know she's dope I actually
saw a tender bar after we worked
together oh nice
yeah look I don't know Steve I really
don't you know I like part of me in my
head I'm like what what was I like the
most terrible at so that then like maybe
I can like try and like you know top
that no subvert expectations yeah yeah
when we work together
yeah no all three of you are really good
in sharper and speaking of sharper I'm
curious one of the things about this uh
is that the film keeps you guessing the
entire way through so I'm curious for
all three of you what was it like
reading the script for the first time
and how much had you been told about
ultimately the arcs or how much were you
reading it the script for the first time
being like holy what is going on here I
think we got everything
um I mean when I read it I was just I
was doing what you explained exactly
just thinking oh I have this figured out
and then 10 pages later it's completely
destroyed and put on its head um and I
knew it'd be a really exciting thing to
experience in a film uh yeah very
exciting
yeah I read it all in one sitting which
is very rare to me because my brain is
broken
um and I can't focus on anything about
you enjoying being watched
I just thought that's what you were just
doing but I do love I don't know what it
is I really like just sitting here we
watch me will you watch me
but no I really I I got through it
pretty quickly because uh it was it was
amazing I never knew where I was gonna
go next and I and I highly suggest
audiences do the same going blind and
and don't don't look up anything about
it um except this interview specifically
because we won't spoil anything but uh
because it'll take you on a wild ride
and you won't be disappointed it was not
a predictable outcome you know like you
don't really like get to read a lot of
things that you don't see that really
surprise you that you don't see what you
know things coming the way that they
they do in this film and it was just
there were all all it didn't explain too
much it was just it just LED you know it
made you kind of
have your own impression and about the
characters and like their backgrounds
without giving you like
too much of explanation you know Brianna
I would imagine that when you were
offered this role it was
um well obviously it's a cool movie but
it allows you as an actor to show so
many different sides of your of yourself
the range of what the character goes
through can you sort of talk about
um playing a character like this that
allows you to show so many different
things yeah
um it was as exciting as it was
terrifying
um I mean it's an it's an actor's dream
to get to play you know essentially
different people in one film uh I was
joking that I don't ever have to
audition against people just need to
watch this film and be like oh okay she
can do that
um no I mean I tried not to get too
heady about uh how different she was and
different points in the film I think I
just tried to lock down on the things
that were similar and
um
to ground me in just a you know a
through line of Truth throughout the
whole movie and if things were different
it was more technical than anything it
was you know body language or um
voice stuff uh yeah I just really tried
to be present justice has been saying
this the whole time like presence is
kind of a good safe place to be the
whole time just dealing with what's in
front of you and playing the sincerity
of it were you ever shooting different
parts of the movie on the same day and
there because each chapter is sort of it
has its own aesthetic so what was that
sort of Life yeah the answer is yes
um the nature of filming in general like
if you have a location booked you're
gonna bang out all the things that are
in that location and so that would often
require us to shoot uh I mean you know
shooting is always out of order but you
know we would shoot kind of we would
overlap different perspectives and pick
up different shots depending on uh which
character we were focusing on in that
part of the movie even though like
earlier that day was like more focused
on my character and then you know later
that day it might be more focused on
Brianna's character or whatever ever
um
but yeah it's kind of all packaged in a
nice organized way so that uh
we can meet our days
because I wanted to see how that thought
was going to end
because I'm my head I'm I you I lost you
like at least no no of course I know
exactly what you're saying I just I I
just I've been there like I know you're
like I knew where this was going
I can see that you guys had a very very
tough time making this movie and you did
not like each other yeah very true it's
so awesome I think we had a lot of fun
and that was one of the things like Ben
would always be like less is more or
less is more at least with me he would
always be like remember just like one
look rather than you know a whole face
of Expressions
um so it was he was actually really
great to because there's a lot of
directors don't a lot of directors don't
give you the technical side of it and
here we got the technical side to go
with you know the emotional uh Direction
Sebastian I'm just I'm I'm just about
out of time but I have to ask you an
individual question
um you obviously are gearing up this
year to play Bucky again it's been a
little while since you've played the
role is it something that you are
looking forward to getting back to uh
and what is it what can you tease people
about Thunderbolts no of course like I
you know as always it's it's always a
pleasure going back and and you know I
think now we have like it's an exciting
time because this character can kind of
go every which way we sort of opened up
the door for him in a lot of ways but I
I haven't read the script I still hasn't
have not been sent it so
um
it's pretty much on par as as how it
usually goes so I've heard good things
um I'm also I think this that the film
I'm really sorry about the cast like
there's a lot of great people in there
like oh that I was really I'm looking
forward to working yeah David Harbor was
telling me that he's looking forward to
shooting stranger things five and
thunderbolts at exactly the same time
that's crazy yeah I don't know how he's
going to do that
uh Atlanta that's hell right maybe he's
not in our movie that much I don't know
he's a great guy I love David
um I gotta rap I'm just gonna say
congrats on the movie uh thank you for
giving me your time I wish you guys
nothing but the best thank you have a
good one